to kind of give you guys a little bit of
insight so here in canada um
because robert and i were talking maybe
about 15 20 minutes prior to that i also
had a conversation with george gammon a
few months prior and we got into the
conversations about real estate um real
estate here as far as placing your money
um you know as an investor to acquire
and hold um
and put tenants in it even unless you're
running it as a full-time business
doesn't make a lot of sense so if you've
got some spare capital and you want to
deploy it and say all right i'm going to
buy a condo here in a house here or
something like that
um
like the last condo that i just sold a
few months ago it was in downtown
toronto and to give you an idea of the
ratios
about eight hundred fifty thousand two
bedroom two bath and when it was uh
generating rental income it was about
twenty eight hundred dollars a month
so not a not a real good ratio right
that's a lot different in many of the
states in the us right like real estate
is a lot more attractive if i'm not
mistaken yeah
yeah yeah
you know the thing about toronto as you
know rich being there i i've spoken all
over canada and i have lots of friends
that do real estate in canada
um you know as you go from let's say the
west coast from let's call it vancouver
you know then to you know maybe calgary
and you just keep moving moving around
each city each province is different
each uh it's the same in the u.s so
you know typically the coasts are a
little bit more
and
yes so the
you know
you can get deals
you know the key to real estate from my
opinion is is
trying to be ahead of where we're going
so
uh you know vancouver blew up way back
in the 80s because of your immigration
when you know you could you could put a
million bucks down and also you could
open a business and you could be
a citizen in the in canada well that
that's uh i don't know if they're still
doing that but that kind of blew up that
that market
and so you know each market's a little
bit different depending on oil and gas
if you go up to the tar sands uh you
know up above calgary and i know that
busted sense and you know so uh it's the
same in the us we have boom and bust
towns based on
you know what's happening in that
particular area
and
towards the end of that um clip that i
just played robert was talking about
being able to put money into real estate
but pay zero taxes on
was it was it the income is it the
capital gains on the property like can
you get some get into some specifics
with that and if tom you need to chime
in on the tax planning stuff let us know
what that looks like too
time if i could step in i'll just show
us a diagram then thumb takes over yeah
yeah go ahead
exactly i'll give you the full screen
just so you can show the diagram yeah
this is the most important part so if it
says they're investing
are you investing from an employee or a
self-employed
or business and
insider
and these guys pay the highest taxes
so when somebody says i'm making money i
want to know from which quadrant they're
investing from so i won't touch a deal
if i'm investing from here again this is
poor dad this is rich dad this academics
he's a capitalist here
but what tom has taught me and my rich
dad taught me to do
is if i have a business which i do
and i make one million dollars here one
million
so the rich dad company makes 1 million
immediately i've got to ask kenny
i need a five million dollar
life enough a five million dollar
liability
so what i'm doing is i'm gonna make a
million dollars here
and i have to find a five million dollar
either rental property oil and gas or
something so they're not the same
transaction
so every time i'm investing i'm on two
tracks
one as a business order
and the other as an investor got it
every year i'm calling ken he said hey
kenny
i need some more i need some more debt i
need some more debt
tom take over
so
so is that through a hold co like here
in canada we call that a holding company
abbreviated down to hold co which is
just a number company which holds your
assets is that what that looks like tom
yeah typically but it's it's not the
it's not the company that makes the
difference it's the asset so it's having
the debt combined so it's
you get a deduction in canada it's the
same okay you get a deduction for a
portion
of the purchase price of the property
right and some of that is accelerated
depending on what type it is so is that
for example is it carpeting and and
window coverings or is it uh you know
land improvements like landscaping or is
it the building itself right everything
wears out at different rates and the
government gives you a deduction we call
it depreciation down here or asset
recovery in some some countries um and
that deduction
is you know it's it's not like the
property is going down in value it's
just that the government gives you a
deduction for wear and tear on the
building and on the property and when
you get debt along with the money you
put in then what happens is you actually
magnify that deduction so robert can
actually take a million dollars by five
million dollars of property and he could
end up with
right now in the us as much as a million
dollar deduction but you know whether
it's a million dollars or 500 000 canada
is probably closer to 500 000 right now
if you if you did that um but you can
really it's what's really interesting
you can really do it in any country
so
so it's structured in in such a way that
a holding company holds that million
dollar asset so let's say that you
generate a million dollars in income on
it and you're sitting on that cash as
long as you take on the five million
dollars in debt in the um let's say you
buy an apartment building with a bunch
of doors
then then that's a wash and there's no
taxes paid exactly
exactly what i'm trying to do is i have
a business as an asset rich dad let's
say
i'm calling i was calling i started
panicking around july and i'm on the
phone to kenny i said kenny what you got
what you got what you got this is the
difference that people have a hard time
realizing
i'm looking for more debt
and when you say more debt you generally
mean like borrowing money from a bank or
real estate investment i need to find
something i can borrow money on and the
reason i say that is so many people
americans canadian they've been taught
to get out of debt live debt-free
so they're honest the opposite so when i
tell people what i what i'm calling
kenny panicking i said kenny how much
debt have you got
and but he's got an asset so let's use
the same numbers one million
five million i now have a six million
dollar asset
and it might be an apartment house in
austin texas
that was the last deal we did right
kenny that was austin
yeah it's 450 doors 455 doors 90 million
and um
is there like a certain region that that
that you guys lean to right now like i
know there's there's there's somewhat of
a migration of
uh citizens from certain states to
places like texas arizona and florida
um have you been targeting like these
growth areas specifically
yeah so we have uh i have about 300
employees at this point we have just
about 10 000 doors
and um
you know our acquisition guys are
constantly looking for obviously where
people are heading
so you know back in the day you can kind
of pick on let's say detroit you know
that was really hot and vibrant now it's
you know there's not a lot of people
going there
and so now that's happening along the
coast so washington oregon california
not exclusively but but a lot of people
are moving out of those areas into other
areas based on all kinds of things so
that yes and so one of those markets
that we're looking at is texas
uh they're obviously not moving
everywhere in texas but there are
certain markets that people are going to
and there's a bunch of cool ways rich
like
uh simple like if you think about it it
makes complete common sense for like
like ryder truck and u-haul u-haul truck
rentals one way i was watching a video
on your channel yeah yeah how do you get
that data yeah it's all on on the on the
internet
north american north american van lines
also out of state driver's licenses as
an example or residency or whatever you
know when you like let's say people are
moving here from washington to arizona
let's say which is where i live
they turn in their driver's license well
that's a data point so
you know last year arizona grew by 98
000 people
north carolina 93
uh texas 321 000 and florida 211 000
those are the top four states
right now do you know
do you actually know what the percentage
growth is versus no not the top of my
head uh you know and that is important
but
the enough you know what happens rich as
you can imagine if you comment went up
let's say a hundred thousand people come
to arizona
if we don't have the supply to
accommodate that then it drives prices
up drives rent up you know it's hard to
get a reservation all that stuff's
happening here in arizona it's happening
in florida it's happening in texas those
states are busy
and the um truck rental companies do
they do they publish that information
about where all their vehicles are
moving to or is that like an insider
thing yeah no you can go right on u-haul
and go on north america and go on rider
and it's actually they'll show you oh
really it's pretty neat yeah yeah just
it's clearly internet right now and uh
so yeah those are those are just some of
the things you wouldn't want to rely on
them completely
but there's also some crazy horror
stories so i'll give you an example i
have a friend that's trying to move from
california
and uh u-haul is going to charge him 10
grand
um
because it's a one-way trip
and it's up to idaho and um so he said
if i get it back to them it's only four
uh so you know there's you know what's
happening is all their their all their
trucks are leaving and they they they
don't have the labor to get them all
back
so there's got to be a market to pay
somebody like a thousand bucks
i'll do it for a thousand bucks yeah i
mean you could put probably put a ad in
a local uh listing and get some kid to
do it with a driver's license right
that's interesting
you